[Music]
welcome to this special edition of
Hannity the Trump effect i'm jason
chaffetz in tonight for sean for the
hour we'll highlight why elections
matter since the president's
inauguration in january 2017 the Trump
effect has been in full swing the
economy is booming the media has been
called out for its abuse of bias and
deep state corruption has been exposed
at some of the highest levels in our
federal bureaucracy and last night
President Trump called on the Department
of Justice to confront that deep state
corruption head-on
take a look our Justice Department and
our FBI at the top of each because
inside they have incredible people but
our Justice Department and our FBI have
to start doing their job and doing it
right and doing it now because people
are angry people are angry what's
happening is a disgrace and at some
point I wanted to stay out but at some
point if it doesn't straighten out
properly I want them to do their job I
will get involved and I'll get in there
by half this week we learned even more
details surrounding a brewing scandal
we've been discussing for months all
surrounding the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act or FISA for short
Judicial Watch now has uncovered that no
FISA Court hearings none took place on
the warrants obtained by the FBI on
former Trump campaign associate Carter
Page of course we know the basis for
that warrant was Christopher Steele's
dirty dossier and yesterday Catherine
Herridge reported that current Muller
deputy Andrew Weissman was kept in the
loop about Steel's dossier joining us
now to break all this down is author of
the Russia hoax the illicit scheme to
clear Hillary Clinton and frame Donald
Trump Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett and Judicial Watch president tom
Fitton thank you both for being here
Greg congratulations on the book I think
it's been the New York Times bestselling
list three weeks in a row three weeks
dinner oh that's got to drive them crazy
it's good
drive them nuts Tom I want to start from
you because you've done some amazing
work I'm a huge fan of what Judicial
Watch has done without you we wouldn't
learn a lot of these things but explain
to us in this court filing what you were
able to uncover the court transcripts
about Karger page and general Flynn they
wouldn't tell us one way or another
whether there was even a FISA warrant on
Flynn
Carter page they did admit that had
taken place they gave us the FISA
applications we said what about the
transcripts they initially said there
were no transcripts and then in an
effort to dismiss the case they filed
something last night saying we asked the
office of intelligence and the within
the Justice Department they told us
there was never any court hearing on any
of the Carter page warrants
there was the initial warrant and then
three subsequent renewals and to me it's
astonishing and disturbing that these
courts couldn't bother to hold hearings
on spy warrants targeting Donald Trump
when you look at these applications
it isn't about Carter page it's about
the Trump campaign it's about candidate
number one president Trump three of
those warrants were filed while he was
either going to be President for when he
was president and these courts that are
supposed to provide oversight of the
secret spy process refused to do so and
of course they were gamed by relying on
the Justice Department than the FBI so
you've got the courts falling asleep at
the wheel here and of course you got the
underlying corruption in the DOJ and FBI
and the leadership of the Justice
Department and FBI are completely out to
lunch in terms of highlighting and
exposing and holding those accountable
responsible for that corruption so Greg
what do you glean from this and the fact
that there was no hearing I mean it's a
one-way court as it is right it's an ex
parte proceeding which means there's
only one side the government side and
there's nobody there to protect the
civil liberties and the privacy rights
that are being intruded upon by the
federal government these judges without
hearing without asking a single solitary
question simply accepted as truthful the
representations of people like James
Comey Andrew McCabe rod Rosen
Stein Sally Yates and now we know they
weren't telling the truth they were
deliberately misrepresenting the facts
they were concealing vital evidence
deceiving the judges and perpetrating a
fraud on the court this is what's wrong
with secret star chambers and it's it's
gotta stop it's got to be corrected in
some form or fashion because the abuse
of power now is rampant and this is what
happens well and the concern is then
when you author they actually put
together that document if they don't
explicitly say or tell the judge that
the Clinton campaign is funding this
right you have to use a decoder ring to
try to figure out and then on top of
that for Judicial Watch to to find out
that there was no hearing tell me about
Andrew Weissman why is this so important
with Catherine Harridge is reporting why
is Weissman so important in what Bruce
or was doing and informing him along the
way Bruce Orr has now implicated the
lead lawyer in Robert Muller's special
counsel team he was in on the Russia
hoax that was framing Donald Trump for
doing things that Trump never did so
Weitzman knew that Christopher Steele
who composed the phony dossier was not
credible they knew that the document was
completely specious it was
uncorroborated unverified and they knew
that Steele had been fired for lying and
yet the FBI in the Department of Justice
and that guy on your screen apparently
didn't care they used it nevertheless to
pursue this phony fabricated
investigation of Donald Trump and to
wiretap an American citizen without
proper evidence so this now ruins the
integrity and the credibility of Robert
Muller Special Counsel wife's women
should be fired and the Special Counsel
himself should say we apologize we are
terminating our special counsel probe
because all of it has been tainted and
corrupted by Weissman yeah they're gonna
have a real difficult time it's not
impossible to get it through the courts
Tom where does Judicial Watch go next
what
what other things do you have brewing
that the court will need to rule on and
what are you pressing for well we were
just told there were 1600 pages of Bruce
or documents they're gonna take six
months or so they want to turn them over
we've sued for Andrew Weitzman's text
messages we're getting the Stonewall on
there we've already shown that wife's
been sent an email to Sally Yates
praising her lawless thwarted of
president Trump's travel ban order back
in the beginning of the administration
now they don't want to turn over any
text messages that mention Clinton or
Trump he's Pro Clinton he she he
attended Clinton's party on the election
night it wasn't much of a party I wish
that I was there at that party by the
way I think that would have been kind of
fun but go ahead sorry but now they're
they're hiding his text messages from us
what why are they hiding his text
messages from us so we're asking for all
these questions and you know you open
the hour with talking about the
president saying he may have to get
involved the easiest way for him to get
involved is the order the Justice
Department and the FBI to quickly
release these records declassify the
rest of those FISA applications that the
court didn't hold hearings on so we can
figure out what's in them because
they're classified to cover up
corruption not because of national
security issues and get the truth out
that's the best way the combat the deep
state at this point well and look
they're not only not only turning them
over to the public which is paying the
bills and that's the government works
for is the public and you're you're at
this the tip of the spear on that but
they're also holding you back from
Congress people like that from John
Radcliffe and trey Gowdy and Devin Nunez
who have security clearances so they
have no excuse there but they continued
all those back of course Greg though one
of the things that's concerning about
this is not just Bruce or but his wife
right Nellie
so where does it go next with Nellie
well she'll be questioned because it's
important laws appear to have been
broken here lucky he he omitted in his
filings of the Department of Justice
that his wife was getting paid for
composing the dossier that he was
peddling now that is not only filing a
false government report which is a crime
but it's also the bribery and gratuity
statute and the honest services fraud
says why he's now squealing on people
like Andrew Wiseman and having Wiseman
heading up this and that's like a
detective who frames a suspect then
appoints himself to investigate the
crimes for which he has framed the
suspect Andrew Weissman is leading the
investigation into Donald Trump and yet
it was Weitzman who was involved in
framing Donald Trump oh and by the way
we'll take the number four person at the
Department of Justice and his wife who
happens to work for this little
organization well then they can have
some communications so egghead quickly
quickly Jason got the dossier was used
by Muller that if Wirth renewal was
signed or Muller's rein Muller is
responsible for the use of the dossier
just as much as these others and that's
where you start to get into who's got
autographs on some of this stuff and the
fire the memo he authored in framing in
firing of director Comey it's so
incestuous that it needs to continue to
be exposed thanks for your great work
both of you we really do appreciate it